rihanna rocks her most skin bearing
pregnancy look yet her best accessory
her growing baby bump but you are making
it look so stylish
well you have to that's the 34 year old
singer rocking an all black number while
stepping out for dinner in santa monica
saturday night riri is wearing alexander
wang head to toe featuring a diamond bra
leather jacket and mini skirt paired
with amina muwadi boots and to complete
the outfit the beauty mogul sports black
gentle monster by coperni sunglasses
[Music]
but that's not the only chic outfit she
worked that day ahead of the dinner
rihanna dazzled in this silver look for
a fenty beauty launch event rocking a
coperny custom crop top and long skirt
the umbrella singer puts her belly on
full display similar to her pregnancy
announcement outfit ree wore a diamond
body chain over her bump this time by
masika
[Applause]
check out this behind the scenes moment
of the mother to be absolutely slaying
while arriving at the event
the journey has been incredible it's
a lot of hard work
and um
just being true to your brand and i've
always tried to stay
and stick with things that i enjoy doing
and mostly
that i'm passionate about we also had
some fun with makeup artist michaela
noguera inside the launch where the
influencer asked the grammy winner this
burning question the people want to know
when the album is but i have a better
question
what song are you most proud of that
you've come out with i love needy me i
also love a good diamond you know
[Music]
and there's no doubt rei's been shining
bright in high fashion looks since
announcing in january that she's
expecting her first child with her beau
asap rocky it's a long nine to ten
months girl you know you you have to
enjoy it last month when eti caught up
with the songstress she gushed about
dressing her baby bunk you were making
it your fashion show i'm trying to enjoy
it as much as i could and fashion is one
of my favorite things so
you know redefining what it means to
even be
pregnant and maternal you know it always
it it can get uncomfortable at times so
you know you can dress the part and
pretend rocky was also there in support
of his lady love where the rapper
revealed what he's most looking forward
to in this next chapter of life i'm just
excited for what i don't know yet you
know everything is new to me so
you know i'm excited
[Music]